this man is gonna be in a big
this is a great game this is a great
game to kick off this season
tennessee titans
arizona cardinals in the great city of
nashville tennessee let's go let's go no
doubt about that derek henry let's roll
let's roll him down hill j.j watt can't
quit the afc south essentially um and
the pro bowl uh left tackle of the
tennessee titans and the uh co-host with
will compton of uh busting with the boys
none other than uh none other than
taylor lewand back here on the show how
are you taylor
i'm wonderful uh rich that was a hell of
an intro to be totally honest with you
when you said i was one of your favorite
people it's true a single tear went down
my cheek and it just it just means a lot
it means a lot to come this far you and
i it means a lot to me too how are you
feeling you good everything good oh dude
i feel like a million domestic right now
i'm so excited to be back out here with
the boys i mean literally for the first
time in my life i was excited to
actually go play football which is oh
like practice not games i love games but
like right like i was getting ready for
camp and i'm like i can't wait to go to
camp which i've never said before my
entire life like i have i have found a
new
weird passion for playing this game it
has been an awesome camp my leg feels
outstanding i'm excited for the boys in
your right there's going to be a great
first game huge test for the boys in all
three phases so i'm i'm really excited
playing from playing a team that i grew
up watching in arizona this is gonna be
a great game that's right you're you're
an arizona kid right that's right desert
rat for life
it's amazing what you miss when you
don't know
what you have right and not to get too
deep but i mean you were out and now
you're back and you're just you're
rejuvenated i love hearing that i love
you yeah
it's definitely been a transition for
sure um you if you go through so many
emotions i've never been hurt hurt
before my life i'm right i got my top of
that when i was 21 and that was a bit of
a deal but
about that from that yeah yeah we can
hit that in a second
but um
i when i you know for the acl it's like
all this optimism okay i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be better i'm gonna be better and
then months four five and six hit and
i'm just in a fat depression like
not the haha joking depression but like
legitimately was physically emotionally
just drained like had nothing to me and
i was like am i ever going to be the
same guy again
and um it just feels good to be back in
the field i feel like the exact same
person i feel quick out of my stance i
feel strong um and i'm just super
grateful and it really put things into
perspective for me for sure like what
seriously let's go let's let's dig
deeper what do you mean right like
perspective like i like uh yeah people
say all the time like hey you never know
your last snap is you know this might be
the last time you guys you know all the
cliches right right remember the titans
all these cliche football like friday
night lights but like legitimately to me
i'm like this might be the last game i
ever played this year like september
12th might be the last purple game ever
play so why hold back anything why worry
about x y and z there's like
it's really giving me an opportunity to
kind of narrow in my sights of what is
truly important
at the moment i'm doing it you know
there's no outside thoughts when i'm
playing football it's literally just
focusing on where i'm at right now and
just being excited to even like play the
game and it sounds literally i'm
listening to myself right now if i was
if i was a viewer listening to me right
now i would immediately change like this
was the dumbest bs i've ever heard
someone say but it's like
legitimately
it's real
it just feels so great to play it again
and it's amazing to realize this
because a lot of these guys man a lot of
these guys come and play
get hurt or it doesn't work out for them
because off the field issues or whatever
and then they wake up five years later
and they can't play the game anymore and
they're like man what an opportunity i
missed
and for me to kind of realize that
in the middle of my career
is uh it's just i'm just super grateful
and super lucky i got a great family and
they've definitely been amazingly
supportive through the whole thing
taylor
you shouldn't think another second about
what you just said seriously i think
fans hear what you just had to say
taylor be and and love it and part of
the reason why is we fans
want to hear from the guys we root for
and are are playing
you know for the team that we root for
we want to hear from them it means just
as much to them as it does to us you
know like that's a fact and sometimes we
feel like it doesn't mean that much to
the people that we're rooting for and
and it must be incredible for you to get
back out there
and look at the freaks of nature that
are on your offense
that you're protecting your quarterback
to go find or blowing the holes open for
for derek henry aj brown and now
obviously julio jones you got a good
julio story for me like where he's just
shown up and he's done something you're
like okay i got it anything like that no
i don't i don't have anything like that
i would say uh his presence as an
individual is definitely way different
than uh most superstars i've been around
in my career because it's a
it's a calmer confidence it's not a like
over the top i'm this i'm that like this
dude
like he doesn't say a whole lot but when
he speaks it's like like the whole room
can be super loud everyone arguing about
a bunch of stuff like classic locker
rooms can be yeah and he'll just start
talking along when we get quiet it's
like okay what's will you gotta say you
know what i'm saying like it's it's wild
how his his presence you know what he's
done this career how he talks and when
you when you sit down and talk to him
for 10 15 minutes you realize why he's a
player that he was he obviously has all
the time in the world but he's got the
mindset to go with it and a lot of times
the way he and i have bonded is blocking
right he's
he
he knows i'm not going to know anything
over a curl route or a poster i don't
know none of that right well he talks
about you know digging out safety and
the way he likes to play in the run game
it's
it fires you up he's a year 12 guy and
the way that um he just operates and
handles himself he's a dude that you
really want to root for so i'm a huge
julio jones fan i was watching from the
distance obviously i mean atlanta's
four hours away but totally a different
division you know in the nfc so you
don't really think about it much
but for me like you always know who that
jones was now he's on our team and it's
just watching the way he operates like
no there's no wonder why this guy's a
first down hall of famer the way he
handles himself on a day-to-day basis
like
he's confident but he's just
he just you can just tell he handles
himself the right way yeah that seems
like to be um
i love that story about in the locker
room and derek henry
what's
i mean what is it like to be his
teammate and also know you're
responsible for
anchoring uh a line
that
that somebody could break the record
behind this year based on what we saw
last year now you got a 17th game and
and all that stuff you know derek is um
i love derek henry as a person i'm there
again as a teammate like yeah that's my
dude like we are we're boys not just off
on the field but off the field as well
um
my favorite thing about derek and and
also the thing that pisses me off the
most about derek yes is if you're in a
game and you let's say i miss a blog
let's say i don't have my hat in the
right place and i let up at tfl
it's not like that plays over because
once we get back to the sideline
i knew i messed up there you know i
messed up but derek's going to walk over
to me and ask hey what happened there
like derek you obviously know what
happened obviously it's like messed up
real bad but you're going to come over
here and say to me but he says it and
then what why why'd that happen and
because it's not because derek wants it
needs his yards or anything he holds the
boys to a high standard he knows what
i'm capable of but it is
in the moment when you know you're kind
of like okay you know this you know 60
000 people here i just got dummied in
front of somebody like not the best
feeling in the entire world then there's
got to kind of egg it on a little bit
more it's like man would love to be in a
hundred different areas right now uh
it's cool that he keeps guys accountable
derek is uh
he expects the most from himself he i
mean this whole this whole nfl you know
the name he has what this team expects
out of him is nothing compared to what
dare he expects out of him so um it's
never too big for him i'm really excited
to watch him play this year taylor lawan
of the titans here on the rich eisen
show how how much can you allow here
publicly about how the offense might be
different with arthur smith now
in atlanta your your offensive
coordinator is now a head coach um last
year's oc is now the hc in the atl how
different are things going to look this
year you know uh that's a great
question and i think the best way to
answer that question is
guys you gotta tune into some football
games trying to figure out what the
difference is maybe we can play a little
game of what's different maybe get some
some uh
warriors some computer warriors out
there maybe they can dissect everything
that's going on but
you know i think uh i think that's a
nice trap question richard i love it
you're a professional in the business
uh being in the game long enough you
know you know when someone's throwing a
jab or a haymaker and buddy that was a
haymaker all right
because i get knocked out i don't wanna
know i just wanna i bet you do
i would you know what i'd say there's
some things that are different there's
some things that are the same and uh
okay well you apply a little bit more of
one in the other maybe all right but i
would definitely watch i tuned in
september 12th maybe we'll see uh some
same things on different things what do
you think okay uh let's crowdsource it
we'll crowdsource it we'll say what's
different you know spot the difference
right anything that's different who who
wears it better the 2021 titans 2020
titans who who are better yeah
like i think we're like that's the great
thing we'll just compare him to arthur
smith for the rest of his life i think
that'll be fun for him and his career
that'll be great i don't want to live
with it but i i tell you what todd i
love todd man he's a good dude that guy
is
he wants his team to be more successful
than anybody else todd is he's he's
going to put us in some good situations
here this year i'm really really excited
all right let's talk about your pod it's
crushing it congrats everything isn't
that wild it's great it's great in that
let's just sit let's just simmer on that
right let's put that marinade okay isn't
that wild
that a couple of flappies bought a
broken down bus
and we're just blowing the hinges off
national podcast we're just
we're burning the midnight oil we're
killing it you're absolutely killing it
and you know what some people might not
like it when you gasp yourself up but
here i am
93 octane in me right now because i'm
gassing myself up this thing is awesome
who do you want on the bus and with the
boys podcast who do you and and will say
like if you had your wish list
because you they also have to come there
right i keep telling you yeah you have
no idea how much better it would be if
you could actually travel the country
you know you put an actual motor in the
damn thing and you actually drive it
around and you look you understand you
understand the business now more than
one you know again i was just trying to
help you and then of course troll on you
and it's in a certain way i possibly
could but like who would you want
on your bus if you could wave a wand
tail a lawn on your pocket oh man it's
uh
i mean the gang the the number one og
podcast is joe rogan
so for for him to come on our pod first
ever love the guy right at the bottom
the man started a cult i'd probably be
the first one drinking the kool-aid
that's how much i love joe rogan it
sounds like he already has to be honest
with you taylor it sounds like yeah it
sounds like you started wild what he's
accomplished but it's also the mind the
way he uh
perceives things and handles his certain
situations it's it's pretty incredible
to have that much depth uh i'm very
impressed by him a little one out from
left field though that i think yes is a
bug listener for me personally now you
have to talk to willy c uh if your
ratings ever you know are okay with
being stagnant for a while have will on
it'll be fine you guys will you guys
will be fine from it but um johnny
knoxville i'm a huge i'm a huge jackass
fan i'm a huge johnny knoxville fan you
know i i might have not had the best um
parental guidance growing up my heroes
like dan margera
johnny knoxville
you know uh nate adams and travis
pastrana like kind of like the uh
the the outcast you know guys that do
wild stuff those are my those are the
heroes i grew up watching i think johnny
knoxville would be an all-time guy to
have in the podcast well i i i can't
help you with the joe rogan one uh
because i don't know if we go we go
shopping at the same horse dewormer spot
but uh but we we do i can't help you
with johnny knoxville you can you can
actually help me enjoy a nutshell yeah
our kids go to school together oh yeah
you're lying are you serious yeah
i've been on i've i've been on pickup
lines with johnny knoxville are you
kidding me i can make that happen let me
help you
this is uh i thought i was doing you a
favor today but here i am no
i'm i'm realizing i'm the man that's
getting the help today taylor please let
me
let me do that you've been so great uh
calling in and whatever and you know um
uh let me do that i'll do that we'll get
that done i think he's got it
i think he's got one last one it landed
one last movie in him that he's going to
be out uh promoting something jackhouse
coming out soon so there you go yeah let
me help you really soon i love the
trailer too they got machine gun kelly
in there which by the way talk about a
glow up right as the kids would say yes
the glow up for machine gun kelly has
been
uh unbelievable the guy goes from a
hardcore uh rapper
and now he's the number one rock star in
the world thanks to uh him and travis
destro travis parker yes good for him i
saw him in the trailer of the jack s4
movie and
uh a huge fan huge fan of all those guys
as well but let's let's focus on giant
knoxville we'll take england and travis
parker eventually i'm i'm on it later
today i'll text you i seriously got it
i'll do it i'm on it yeah put us in a
group here let me let me uh wow
yeah
it would be it'd be my pleasure taylor i
love hearing how you're bouncing off the
walls and you're fired up man it crushed
me last year when you got hurt and um
i'm i'm thrilled that you're rejuvenated
i cannot wait to see what you're cooking
up with the rest of your mates for 2021.
well i really appreciate that thank you
for having me on guys really always a
pleasure
all right man we'll we'll chat soon
you'll be well everybody that's taylor
want everybody michigan man as well hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here